>>
Hi. There it is. Okay.
Welcome to today's event.
On behalf of Authors at Google and Women at
Google, it is my privilege to introduce Jennifer
Jordan.
Jennifer is an award-winning filmmaker and
author.
Her film, "Women of K2", will be screened
tonight at 6:15, at the Mountain View Center
for the Performing Arts, as part of the Mountain
View Reads Together program, which is featuring
the book, Three Cups of Tea.
Jennifer is here to talk about her book "Savage
Summit", the true stories of the first five
women who climbed K2, the world's most feared
mountain.
She twice lived at the base of K2 while writing
and researching her book, which won the National
Outdoor Book Award in 2005.
Following the talk, we'll have a Q and A session,
and I ask you to please use the microphone
for a remote audience.
And now, please join me in welcoming Jennifer
Jordan.
>> [Clapping]
Jennifer Jordan: Thank you so much.
Taking time out -- well, I was going to say
"taking time out of your busy day," but you
brought your busy day with you.
We -- in Salt Lake, we don't take our computers
everywhere.
So it's fun to see you always connected.
It's great to be here.
I love coming to California, because I get
that much closer to the ocean.
Coming from -- I lived in Boston for years
until I moved out to Salt Lake seven years
ago.
So it's wonderful to be back within arm's
breadth.
People ask me a lot whether I've climbed K2,
and I always say you know, "Have you seen
the thing? Are you kidding me? I'm not about
to climb that mountain."
I came to high-altitude mountaineering quite
innocently.
I was anchoring NPR's "All Things Considered"
in Boston, in May of 1996, when I heard that
eight people had died on Everest in a single
day.
And I knew probably next to nothing about
high-altitude climbing, but I knew that the
high-altitude mountaineering had changed in
those deaths -- had changed forever, with
that many people dying.
And, with many of them being experienced guides
and some of the world's best climbers who
were part of the toll.
And the world reacted with shock and many
questions.
And many questioned, "Why would anybody risk
so much for a mountain?"
But it was really the women who fascinated
me.
Because, I can almost understand a man's drive
-- almost.
After all, they are the ones with the hunting
instinct and not a small measure of testosterone.
And, "But what on earth" I thought, "explained
women's desires to risk their lives in the
unrelenting world of high altitude?"
After all, I'm a woman. I love the outdoors.
I love a good challenge.
But I don't love any of them enough to risk
my life to get there.
And most women seem to agree with me.
In fact, only five percent of Himalayan climbing
-- the population -- is female.
And by 'Himalayan', I mean, those 14 peaks
that stand above 8,000 meters that are scattered
through Nepal, Tibet, and Pakistan.
But that still leaves five percent who are
willing to enter this grueling and perilous
sport.
Why? The questions that I heard came from
all different, you know, areas of my research.
And I heard you know, "Because we're all adrenaline
junkies."
To, "It's a life-changing experience to stand
at the top of the world." Never, by the way,
have I heard, "Because it's there."
You know, I don't think there is really any
one answer.
I think that the same way that there's no
one answer to being why a parent makes someone
feel more alive, and why you love that person
over there and not that person over there.
I think it's who you are and who you want
to be.
And it's just that some of us are better built,
both emotionally and physically, for the torture
and triumph of high-altitude climbing.
And let's face it, some of us just look better
doing it.
Araceli Segarra, if you don't know her or
have seen her in the Everest film about the
Everest tragedy -- she's a beautiful woman.
She was our teammate in 2002 to K2.
But, I will tell you this -- I've learned
that, at its best, high-altitude climbing
is about joy, pride, iron will, and graceful
suffering.
And those, who are engulfed in its cruel beauty,
experience something rare and sacred, deep
within their souls.
At times, I would love to be among them.
But, in my more rational moments, I'm very
thankful to be writing and reading about them
instead.
Earlier, I said my fascination with the big
mountains and women's place on them started
with the Everest tragedy, but it was fed by
reading "Into Thin Air" and trying to imagine
what life was like in that Death Zone, that
magic mark around 25,000 feet where life slowly
suffocates to death.
As I read the book, I wondered why one climber
-- one woman, Sandy Hill Pittman of New York
City -- was singled out for shame and blame
in the tragedy.
And it seemed to me that she was vilified
for who she was rather than what she did.
She was after all, a client, not a guide.
She was taking orders, not giving them.
So I wondered, "Was she more a victim of her
strong personality than of her behavior on
the mountain that day?"
And, one of the joys of being a journalist
is, I could find out.
And when I interviewed many of the other survivors
of that deadly storm, I heard a very different
story.
I was told that Sandy Hill was strong and
experienced climber.
David Breashears called her, "fearless."
And if any of you know David or know of him,
you know that's high praise indeed.
In fact, Sandy had every right to be on the
mountain that day.
She had a bad summit day, and collapsed.
But you know what?
She wasn't alone.
Eight people died, and many of them, the world's
best climbers.
No, in my opinion, it seemed that Sandy Hill
simply wasn't liked.
And the man who didn't like her had a very
powerful pen.
Maybe it was her wealth or her confidence,
something -- whatever the reasons.
"Into Thin Air" has forever damned Sandy Hill.
And, as a woman -- with my own measure of
pride and confidence -- it affronted me.
And it shocked me to realize how close we
strong women all are to becoming publicly
destroyed because someone, who is powerful,
doesn't like us.
So I came to this story, "The Women of K2",
with an itch and some suspicions that, "Perhaps
women climbers have been unfairly treated
-- not only by the men with whom they climb,
but by those who were writing their stories."
When I found this story in 1998, only five
women had climbed the mountain, and each of
them had died -- three on their descent of
K2, and two on two of the other 8,000-meter
peaks.
And, as I get more and more immersed in the
history, I was amazed to find that, in the
scores of books on the so-called "Savage Mountain",
female climbers were just footnotes in this
history.
No one had written the stories of these incredible
women.
So I get this crazy notion that I -- the journalist
from Boston, the flattest of flatland -- would
write the book and give these pioneers their
due place in climbing history.
But I knew that -- in order to do a credible
job -- I had to go to K2, and I'd have to
see this mountain for myself, which I did
twice, as you heard.
The first thing you have to understand is
that, for women, the challenges of the mountain
begin not at Base Camp, but the minute they
enter patriarchal Pakistan.
Hoping to show some respect and keep a low
profile in the heart of Islam, I decided to
wear the traditional shalwar kameez, but I
needn't have bothered.
Western women walk through life with a purpose
and a sense of power that many women who are
raised in patriarchal societies do not.
So you can dress us up, cover us up head to
toe, and still, the square shoulders and the
head held high and the straight on, "look
you in the eye" of a western woman can be
seen a mile away.
It's a world of men, where women are largely
not seen or heard.
And, in the eyes of some, the square shoulders
and confidence of a western woman simply aren't
welcome.
By the time I got to Base Camp, I was exhausted.
In part from the ten-day, 65-mile trek.
And in part from being an object of fascination
and derision -- even contempt -- from the
constant strain and company of men.
I felt like I'd ground a layer of enamel off
my teeth, I was so frustrated.
But I said to myself, "You know what? At least
I don't have to climb the mountain."
And I realized that the women who do, perhaps
have two mountains to conquer.
One of them is, the mountain in front of them.
And one of them is, the men at their backs.
And, you know, it's an incredibly arduous
climb, even when you do it -- like Wanda Rutkiewicz
did in '82 -- on crutches.
She had broken her femur in training for the
mountain, and she refused to give up the expedition.
So she went in on crutches.
She went through 25 pairs of crutches on her
way in.
I'm not saying that all women face opposition
from men in the mountains.
But my suspicion is that many do.
All five of the women of K2 did.
And most of the women I interviewed for the
film and book told me stories of frustration
and pain at the hands of at least one of their
male teammates.
When I asked the legendary rock climber Lynn
Hill why she was never interested in high-altitude
climbing, she said, "Because I don't need
to put up with the B.S.
of Base Camp."
But the women of K2 did put up with it, and
others will continue to put up with it, so
long as their souls are enriched by attaining
summits beyond the reach of most.
Because, along with the agony and ecstasy,
and among the petty and cruel, are life partners
and friends.
High-altitude climbing is a dangerous -- often
deadly -- intoxicating, humbling, and exhilarating
endeavor.
And those who pursue it, do so for the glorious
payoff of breathing that rarefied air that
veils the top of the world.
In writing the "Women of K2" and "Savage Summit",
I hope I've honored the strong women among
them -- those intrepid few who shatter ceilings
and challenge traditions to realize passion
on their own terms.
And I want to close with a reading.
And then, we can take some questions.
[reading] The last time I approached K2, rounding
the famous corner in Concordia and seeing
it there, sitting ten miles up the glacier,
I bent over my trekking poles and sobbed.
I simply knew too much.
I knew I was looking at the graveyard of scores
of people, five of whom I'd come to know tenderly
-- lovingly.
And I knew my days would be spent in anxious
worry, watching Jeff -- my love and partner
-- inch his way up the mountain that had
killed so many.
It was June 17th, 2002, and we were heading
into the mountain to film the attempt of Spanish
climber, Araceli Segarra, to become the sixth
woman to climb K2.
Jeff would not only be filming her, but climbing
with her on a mountain known for its savage
weather, catastrophic avalanches, and unrelenting
rockfall -- all of which make K2 one of the
deadliest mountains on earth.
And, even if our small team of four made it
to the summit, their chances of dying on descent
were greater than on any other mountain on
earth -- one in seven.
So I knew that, sitting at the Base all summer
and watching them climb the mountain was going
to be tough, and I was right.
It was two months of unrelenting worry, sadness,
and strain.
While my team climbed, I walked the glacier
and found the heartbreaking and grotesque
bits and pieces of some of the scores who've
died on the mountain, and then, buried in
crevasse their broken remains.
Finally, the day of our departure came.
I woke that morning, as the sun breached the
northeast ridge of Broad Peak, and I got out
of my tent feeling an odd happiness.
Something was different.
My nose rose high, searching the air like
a wolf looking for dinner.
My body knew what it was before my brain did,
and I smiled.
Wood smoke -- that beautiful, sweet, warm
smell of my childhood in Vermont.
Like pied pipers, we all walked toward the
source and found ourselves guests at, what
was probably, the world's highest cremation
ceremony.
Seven years before, a team of Japanese climbers
had been swept off the slope while they slept
in their tents, an enormous avalanche throwing
them into the deep crevasse.
Earlier that summer, five of their bodies
had been found, and two of the remaining teammates
had ventured from Japan, along with 120 porterloads
of special wood and kerosene to give them
a proper burial.
I sat at a distance from the flames, trying
not to enjoy too much the pure, visceral pleasure
of a wood fire -- trying to remember that
wasn't only wood that was burning.
Occasionally, one of the Japanese would throw
a gallon-sized container of kerosene on the
fire.
And they would explode into the thin air in
a burst of red and black, the picture-postcard
K2 visible through the flames.
I watched the five pyres slowly dissolve,
their tepee stacks falling into the centers
and onto the bodies beneath.
Then, I saw a white cage of ribs emerge from
the red coals.
It was another.
In another, I began to make out a bent arm.
In another, a perfectly round skull.
My selfish pleasure dissolved; and feeling
numb, mute, and heavy with sadness, I watched
the bodies dissolve.
I looked at the five, distinct cairns.
Not four, not six, but five.
How odd that just five of the Japanese were
found, and here I was, witnessing the one-and-only
cremation at K2 Base Camp in history.
Here they were burning before my very eyes,
the five, lost Japanese.
The five women of K2.
How eeriely ironic that five women had climbed
it, and although two made it off alive, another
two had died trying.
So five women remained up there, down here,
somewhere.
None of their families were here to usurp
this ceremony for their loved one.
So I thought I might as well.
This was also the funeral for the women of
K2.
How they had lived and the facts of their
death had consumed me for years -- too many
years.
My fascination began, as it always does for
most journalists, I was consumed with compelling
facts -- the five lives, the five deaths,
the one mountain.
But as that research developed into a book
and a documentary, my emotions ranged from
fascination to obsession to sadness to anger,
as I delved deeper and came to know the women
with an intimacy not shared by some of those
closest to them.
I began to get mad.
I felt like a parent whose emotions turn to
rage after losing a child to a random murder
or a stupid accident.
Why didn't the women see trouble coming?
Why didn't they turn around?
Why did they try to cheat the mountain by
going to K2 before they had more experience?
How could they have been so blind, driven,
selfish, you name it.
I had these adjectives for my blame and judgment.
But, as I came to the end of my research,
I finally came to peace with their deaths.
I saw that they lived heroically, and that,
even though they died too young, they did
not die senselessly.
They lived in passion and died in stillness,
doing what they loved in a place that fed
their souls.
Someone had told me that, when a climber dies
in the mountains, it's not a tragedy; it's
fate, and that's where they wanted to be.
Another climber told me that he never felt
quite so alive as when he climbed at the edge
of death.
And the closer he got, the more alive he felt.
I finally realized that, although I didn't
celebrate living at that edge, I couldn't
condemn these five women -- or the mountains
-- when they themselves accepted the risks.
Most of us will not choose where we die.
But climbers who enter their deadly arena
know they are dancing on that razor's edge
with every movement they make.
They don't mind the risk.
In fact, they embrace the risk as part of
the price of such unbridled joy.
If they accept their fates, so must I.
I finally realized that I had to understand
that, given the choice, the women of K2 would
have chosen to die right where they did, rather
than rotting from cancer or being crushed
in an automobile accident or slipping into
the long dark tunnel of Alzheimer's.
If they had peace, who was I to judge that
quiet happiness?
Their choice to live and die in the mountains
was one of passion, purpose, and talent, not
idle arrogance or selfish whim.
They were talented climbers, and they found
their greatest purpose in the mountains.
The women of K2 were mothers and daughters,
wives and lovers, sisters and aunts, rivals
and friends.
Their deaths are losses for all of us.
But the way they lived should be a lesson
for all of us.
Perhaps losing so many good women in such
a relatively short period of time -- 1986
to 1998 -- has kept other women from becoming
high-altitude climbers.
Most women today, who are becoming climbers,
choose to stay away from the 8,000-meter game
-- instead excelling on rock and ice, like
Lynn Hill, Catherine Destivelle, and Nancy
Feagin.
Some say the commitment of a Himalayan expedition
is too great.
Others -- who venture into Alpine climbing
in their 20's -- quickly retire early when
they hit their childbearing years, to stay
close to home for their children and families.
Some simply don't think the risks of high-altitude
and all the macho B.S. are worth it.
Regardless of the reasons, most women climbers
just don't aspire to high altitudes' risk
and rewards.
Today, there is no Wanda Rutkiewicz -- no
apparent heir to her strength, determination,
and sacrifice; no follower who can claim bragging
rights to her legacy.
Alison Hargreaves was well on her way, but
fate and foul weather changed her plans.
[talking] And I'm going to zip ahead.
[reading] Five women have many people in their
lives: husbands and lovers, children and siblings,
mothers and fathers, friends and adversaries.
The five women of K2 were no exception.
One of my joys in being a writer and a journalist
is, the privilege I've had to meet and interview
people who most interest me.
Over the years, I've been amazed and disappointed,
shocked and chagrinned, enraptured and disgusted,
bored and enthralled.
But nothing prepared me for getting to know
the people, the women of K2 left behind.
With every new person I found, every fact
I learned, every controversy I unearthed,
I scratched away at the veneer of their lives,
learning things I sometimes had no right to
learn, talking with people who hadn't spoken
since the woman's death, or since their love
affair with her had ended.
I spoke with families who hadn't yet found
closure, siblings who never had a chance to
say good-bye, lovers who were unacknowledged,
and children who were sad and confused at
having played second fiddle to a monolith
of rock and ice.
The women of K2 left a tapestry of grief behind
them.
Because, even though each climber and her
family knew the risks involved, when someone
is actually lost, the hole they leave is raw
with unsaid words, unlived potential, and
unrealized dreams.
[pause] That's it.
I was going to read on, but you know, it's
just -- I'm going to get too emotional.
I haven't read these passages in a long time.
It's even hard for me.
But, thank you for coming.
I welcome your questions, your comments.
And please, if you have any -- or either or
both -- go to the microphone, because we are
taping the proceedings. [pause]
Shocked? Shocked into silence?
Q Was there a particular woman that affected
you, or impacted you, more than others?
Jennifer Jordan: Well, I think that Wanda
Rutkiewicz, I felt most akin to.
She was definitely a very, very assertive,
and you know, some say 'selfish' and 'stubborn'
and 'bull-headed' and all the adjectives that
strong women get.
And I kind of relived -- she had a series
of really heartbreaking denunciations from
within the climbing world in Poland that just
broke her heart right before she died.
I mean, just really devastated her.
And I just, you know, you read the history
and, you know, it came down to a "he said/she
said."
And "You lied" and "No, I didn't."
And to have your climbing career tarnished
in that way -- for someone like Wanda -- was
just devastating.
So I felt that kind of societal -- global,
whatever -- pain of hers in a way that the
others -- you know, they were all really tough.
I -- almost every day, I cried at the keyboard,
because, you know, you just get so far into
these lives and then deaths.
And you talk to these people who, I mean.
Liliane Barrard was the second woman to climb
K2.
She did it with Wanda, but an hour later.
So Wanda was the first, and then Liliane.
They were on the same team.
And Liliane and her husband both disappeared
on descent.
And her body was found that same summer, about
a month later, that she looked like she'd
fallen the distance.
And Maurice's body was found 12 years later.
In any case -- so that was 1986, and I started
Googling -- I don't know how people wrote
books before Google or the Internet.
And was trying to find information on her,
because there's just almost nothing written.
And I talked to all the people who were on
the expedition that year, on the mountain
that year.
"Do you remember Liliane?"
"Oh," they'd say, "You know, I remember she
had a really pretty smile, and she was very
quiet."
And this is the second woman who climbed K2.
And she has a pretty smile and was quiet.
That's all they remembered.
So I was, you know, you delve deeper and deeper
and deeper, and as I get deeper, I found out
she had a brother.
And it didn't help that she was French and
didn't speak -- nothing in English.
And so anyway, so I started Googling literally
"Alain Bontemps, Paris."
Ding.
And then, woop, up comes an Alain with an
e-mail address.
"My name is, I'm researching your sister,"
You know, "Remember the K2? Are you the brother
of Liliane Barrard?"
Next morning, got to my e-mail.
Not only, "Yes, I am," but "I have footage
of her climbing on G2.
Might you be interested?"
And so, I interviewed him, and he sobbed over
the phone.
I was the first person, outside of the immediate
rush of her death, to have any interest in
her -- this is his only sibling; both parents
were gone.
And that really broke my heart that these
women -- and particularly, Liliane and Julie
Tullis, the third woman to climb K2 that same
summer and died on descent -- just kind of
disappeared. Pat?
Q What surprised you, as you were doing the
research?
Were there any surprises?
Jennifer Jordan: Oh, no. You've got to narrow
it down for me.
There were too many.
Q Surprises about the women.
Jennifer Jordan: Surprises about the women.
Even that's a broad question, but thank you
for narrowing it down.
I guess, I was surprised how lonely they all
were.
They all really struggled to climb.
And I wasn't prepared for that.
I mean, when I started the research -- yes,
I started through the Sandy Hill story.
But Sandy's not a high-altitude climber.
You know, Sandy really did decide to climb
the seven summits as kind of a, you know,
midlife thing.
And she trained well.
And she was a good, strong climber, but it
wasn't her life's passion.
These women were pulled into it.
I mean, it's almost as if they didn't choose
it; it chose them.
And I wasn't ready for that.
I wasn't ready for their really, giving their
lives to it, as if they had no choice -- and
maybe they didn't.
I mean, to live with that kind of passion.
It would be like, you know, Michael Phelps
deciding he wants to stop swimming and take
up golf -- which he may do, I mean, the golf
part -- but he'll never not swim, because
he's got a passion for it.
So that surprised me.
I wasn't ready for these women to have been
chosen by climbing.
And then, to really find out how isolating
it was to be in that five percent -- and the
top of that five percent -- of female, Himalayan
climbers.
You know, each of these five women had milestones.
They were firsts on something, and that was
a very lonely, isolating thing.
I mean, it was sad for me to see that the
climbing community -- and even some of the
men they were with -- didn't necessarily care.
I mean, when I started again, Googling -- I
mean, when I found out that -- the only five
women to climb K2 sitting on Charlotte Fox's
porch in Aspen.
And Charlotte's one of the survivors of Everest
'96, so I was interviewing her.
And she knew I didn't know a thing.
She could tell within three sentences that
I was, you know, "flatlander doing some research."
So she said -- she was going through a magazine
for an article she wanted me to read.
And she came across an obituary.
She says, "Hmm. look at that. Chantal just
died on Dhaulagiri.
That means all the women of K2 are dead."
And she looked and raised her eyebrow, "You
know where K2 is, right?"
I said, "Sure." I had no idea.
She said, you know -- because she was very
Charlottsy kit -- "K2 second highest mountain
in the world, only five women have climbed
it.
And now that Chantal's dead, they're all dead.
There's not one survivor."
And just something clicked in me that had
to follow that.
So I went, you know, as soon as I got to a
computer, I was like, "Women of K2, deaths."
Nothing. Nothing, nothing, nothing.
And I thought, "Wow, how can?"
I mean, why didn't David Roberts find this
story?
Why didn't Galen Rowell find this story?
I mean, all these mountain writers.
This is a great story. Why didn't they?
Nobody, not even a magazine article connecting
them.
There's one here about her, one here about
her, but not a collective look at these women
-- and that just floored me.
But again, it gets back to that isolation
thing, that they really were kind of overlooked.
Q And when you were there -- at the second
Base Camp I guess -- did you have any itch
to go a little bit further maybe?
Jennifer Jordan: She's asking this, because
she asked it at lunch, so she knows the answer.
I mean, I am an arrogant athlete, so yes.
I looked at that mountain and thought, "Oh,
c'mon. You know, how hard could it be?"
But that was my arrogant athlete talking.
I mean, I knew how hard it was.
And I knew that, if I even flirted with the
hubris of putting my foot on the climbing
route, I was risking -- not only my death,
but my team's death.
I don't have the skills.
I don't have the -- I was going to say 'temperament'
-- but it's much more the emotional training.
Because you've got to figure out how to suffer.
And you've got to figure out how to suffer
when it hits the fan at 8,000 meters and you
don't have a rope.
And we saw this summer on K2.
A lot of the people that died this summer
didn't have -- in my opinion -- didn't have
a lot of high-altitude experience to know
how to handle catastrophe when it hits at
8,000 meters.
And so, no. I knew better.
The base was challenging enough as far as
being at 17,000 feet and crevass-laden and
littered with dead bodies and body parts.
I mean, Hector -- who was on our expedition
on this second time in 2002 -- started calling
me 'the bone collector', because every time
I'd go out for my walk -- they'd be climbing
or they'd be setting the route or resting
between climbs -- and I'd take my daily walk
and find -- I mean, I almost never came back
to camp without a remnant of sorts.
Excuse me, some of them benign.
Some of them, you know, glove or hat.
And then, you get into the boots, and you
know that that's not good.
Climbers don't leave boots on mountains.
And then, you get into ropes, and then, bones
and parts.
Because the topography of K2 -- unlike Everest
when people die -- K2 is so much steeper.
And it's also in a really active, earthquake
zone.
This is what we keep saying, of course, southern
Pakistan.
And the winds and the everything else -- everything
that was once on K2 gets avalanched or blown
or falls off.
So it ends up at the base.
And that's where I spent my summer, collecting
bones and burying them and, occasionally,
the bodies.
So it was a gruesome summer.
It's not a happy summer.
Q [inaudible]
Jennifer Jordan: The question is, How long
did it take me to write the book and make
the film?
I really started the research for the book
in '98 when Chantal died.
I mean that got me to the library, and then
to Google, thank God.
And so, '98 started the research.
And I went to K2 for the first time in 2000,
and spent, you know, four months on that expedition.
And came home just shattered, because it was
a very dysfunctional team -- a very angry
team, a very troubled team.
And we all just kind of licked our wounds
and went to our corners.
So I didn't come home with the book at that
point.
And then, a year-and-a-half later -- well
actually, a year later -- we were, right after
9/11, Araceli called Jeff and said, "I want
to try K2 this summer, 2002. Can you be on
the team?"
And he's like, "I can't afford to be on the
team unless I'm working."
So we then pitched some friends of ours at
Nat Geo.
So we sold the film first.
And then went over, did that research.
The film took -- with pre- and post- production
and the expedition -- about a year and a half.
And then, I came home from putting that together
and started the book.
And the book took six months to write.
It was interesting.
The first time I wrote it, I wrote it very
much like a journalist; I wrote it like a
magazine article.
And my editor came back and said, "No, we
really want more of a nonfiction narrative."
So I rewrote it. And I'm glad I did.
I think a lot of the readers that have e-mailed
me have said that they found it one of the
most readable mountain books.
So I'm glad about that, because I'm not a
climber.
I knew I couldn't fake the climbing part.
I could do as much research as I could do,
but I had to fill in my experiential gap with
good writing.
So I hope I did that.
Q [inaudible]
Jennifer Jordan: The most challenging part
about making the movie was, making it in Hollywood
with a lot of executives.
I was telling Pat and Charlene over lunch,
it's just -- it was unbelievable to me how
they fight battles just to fight battles -- even
though it would have been a better film, would
have been more comprehensive, but they just
fight them to fight you.
So I lost a few battles, which bothered me.
And that was tough, because we left some of
the best stuff on the cutting room floor just
because of ego wars and time.
You know, we pitched an hour-and-a-half and
they gave us an hour, which on television
is 47 minutes.
So, that was tough.
The hardest part of the book was sobbing over
the keyboard every day.
And just the incredible self-doubt of knowing
that the climbing community that had been
criticizing me for my first day on that first
expedition, "Who are you to write a climbing
book?"
I just had this horrible, gut-wrenching fear
of the reviews -- of John Krakauer writing
a review.
I don't slam him, but I'm not really kind
to him in the book.
But it didn't happen. The critics were silent.
So that was a relief.
But it kind of stained the process, because
it was so -- it was not only a difficult subject,
but it was also very -- I've never written
a biography, and to write five?
It was very, very tough.
And then, I felt like I had all this information
that no one else had ever gathered.
I felt like I was kind of a caretaker of these
women's legacies.
And I wanted to be honest, and I wanted to
be, you know, plain with the truth.
But I didn't want to, you know, I didn't want
to tabloid it.
So making the decision, "Do I expose that
love affair? Are the children going to read
this?"
You know. That kind of thing.
It was an ongoing, constant decision-making
process of, How much do I reveal?
And to whom?
Q So I read the book, and I found it a real
page-turner.
But I'm wondering if you could describe what
were some of the issues particular to women
that you described in the book.
And did you personally experience any of those
on your trip in 2000?
I don't know if there were other women present?
Jennifer Jordan: I did. And I, you know, it's
still difficult.
When I eventually write the book, because
I will, because it was an incredible expedition.
But I can't write it yet, because I'm still
too -- it was eight years ago, and I'm still
too emotionally raw or angry or sad or all
those things to write about that expedition.
So a lot of incredible -- and the kind of
ugly stuff that you just, you can't believe
it's going on.
And what happens at Base Camp is that it's
a lawless community.
And the people there are a personality type
in a life -- personality type that is, you
know, very egotistic -- men and women, it's
not just men.
Very egotistic, very driven, very self-centered,
in the true meaning of the word.
And very frustrated.
On a mountain like K2, you spend most of your
time waiting for the weather to break.
So you got all this broiling stuff.
And so, you know, you -- the bullies are looking
for victims.
And the victims are just trying to hide.
And I was a victim, because I wasn't a climber
-- I wasn't on the team.
You know, I was there as a journalist from
Boston, for God's sake.
You know 'Harvard' on the resume, God forbid.
And it was just unrelenting.
And you know, so I survived that.
And then, went back in 2002 with a small group
-- Araceli, Hector, Armando, Jeff -- fabulous
expedition.
We still had issues, but fabulous group of
people.
And I thought that, "Okay, that had been a
bad expedition for me."
You know, and I did my research.
And these women had their issues, but you
know, I wasn't going to -- I thought it was
perhaps rare that my expedition was that ugly.
And then, I got home, and the book came out.
And a total stranger -- it's a small world
in Salt Lake.
So she found my phone number.
And she called me up, in tears, and said,
"Oh, my God. I thought it was just me."
I said, "What are you talking about?"
And she told me a story that she had been
to the north side of K2 -- only woman on a
large American expedition -- and the men shat
in her shoes.
And that had been just 18 months before.
And I was like, "Why?"
She said, "Well, they didn't like me."
So, it's just -- I mean, it really -- it's
the kind of behavior that you just don't know
how to process.
And, looking back from sea-level, with you
know, my brain cells back where they should
be and -- it's very hard to look at.
Because it just doesn't make sense.
And the behavior is so beyond -- and most
mountain writers won't talk about it.
Because it's just too ugly and it's the tabloid
world and people don't understand it.
And if you've never been to 8,000 meters,
you can't judge, and you hear all that.
So, it's really, yeah. And it keeps going
on.
And, in fact, Charlotte -- I'll betray a confidence.
She -- I interviewed her for the book and
film.
And throughout, for years -- I mean, I met
her in '98.
And for years, she said, "No, no, no, Sandy
got the bad end of that stick.
It's Krakauer this and Sandy's difficult.
But I had a great time.
I always have a great time. I love expeditions.
I'm one of the guys. I'm strong. I'm capable.
Blah blah blah."
She read the book.
Again, called me in tears, and said, "Oh,
my God," and just ranted -- ranted about what
she had been through.
And so, there are a lot of women out there
who don't even want to share it, because they
don't want to be pariahs.
You still need a climbing team.
It's very hard to put a team together.
And especially for women, because there are
not that many of us -- them -- climbing.
So it's troubled.
And I'm sorry to kind of rant, but it's still
obviously very difficult for me.
And I can't -- until I can process it, I can't
really do it justice, because it needs to
be done.
I need to write that book, but I can't write
it yet.
It's still too fresh -- eight years later.
But that's what, you know.
You know, those of us who were bullied?
Any of you guys bullied in school?
It never goes away.
And it's just, you know, when you're bullied
at 42 years old, it really never goes away,
but. [pause]
Q I've read a few mountaineering books --
Jennifer Jordan: Oh, good.
Q -- and yours is different.
And one of the ways that it was really different
for me was, it affected me emotionally much
more than a recounting by Jim Wickwire or
whatever, Roberts.
And the thing -- for example, Julie, right?
And I read that, and I was just angry.
I mean, I was getting emotional. I was angry
at Dan Berger.
I was angry at her. It was interesting.
Jennifer Jordan: Oh thank you. You know, the
Julie.
Do I have time to read that? Good.
I'm going to read you one more passage, because
I think it gets to your point.
And I'll tell you this about Julie.
When the lawyers at HarperCollins and I sat
down to vet the book -- you know, go through
-- and something that didn't happen to you-know-who
a few months ago.
Anyway, didn't want to get into politics.
She said, "Let me just tell you two things.
Number one, I consider Holiday Inn roughing
it.
So I don't know how you went to K2."
And that made me laugh, because, if there's
anything I can do, it's rough it.
And she said, "Second of all. I don't like
Julie."
She was angry at Julie for the choice that
she made, and I wasn't.
I didn't get angry -- I got angry at Julie
for not introducing -- not taking the time
to meet her son's girlfriend.
Remember that scene at the airport?
Where she looks right through him, because
the press is there?
Okay. Anyway.
One of my incredible challenges in writing
this book is that I, not only am not a climber,
I was not with these women when they died
-- any of them.
I found the story after Chantal died -- after
the last one died.
So, I had to write five biographies; I had
to write five deaths, none of which I witnessed.
So I knew I couldn't -- I didn't want to do
just, you know, "Julie died on August 3rd,
1986."
I didn't want to do that.
You have magazine articles for that.
So I wrote this in this style instead.
[reading] And Julie and Kurt had made the
summit of K2.
On the way down, for some inexplicable reason,
Kurt went first on the rope.
They were roped together, not to the mountain
-- and Julie behind, which you just don't
do, because the strongest person has to be
above.
And for some reason, I guess he was just desperate
to get down.
He went first.
She fell, and pulled him with her.
And as with a tea kettle, boom di boom boom.
And finally, he was able to self-arrest them
with his ice ax, bullet-proof ice, dark.
And in the process, she was probably concussed.
We'll never know, because she died up there.
But she was probably concussed.
So this is -- they made it back to Camp Four
-- she, on all fours.
And they had to get into separate tents, because
theirs had collapsed.
They had this, just piece of crap, little,
bivouacy tent that couldn't withstand the
storm that they got stuck in at Camp Four,
so.
[reading] Julie lay in her sleeping bag awake,
but she could feel sleep pulling her down
into its comforting womb.
Villi, Alfred, and Hans were so close that
she could barely distinguish where her breath
ended and theirs began, but she had clunk
in with three other climbers in a two-man
tent, so it's four of them in a two-man tent.
[reading] Their long leg bones pushed against
hers.
Their arms occasionally knocking her head
or chest.
Their beards were coated in the same frost
as the hair that framed her face.
She stared up at the tent, bucking and fluttering,
in the constant roar of wind.
She'd been in storms before -- both here on
K2 and on Everest -- but this was different.
She had gone from panic to anger to dread,
and now, to what?
She hardly felt a thing.
Her blurred vision helped her stay cocooned
away from the worst of the reality they faced.
The men were taking good care of her.
The Koreans had left them a well-stocked tent.
And she drank as much tea as her shrinking
stomach could handle.
Eating was more difficult, but she managed
to choke down some dry bread and some odd,
fishy soup.
As the wind screamed over the tent fabric
and pushed anew at its poles, she thought
of Terry and Chris and Lindsay -- her family.
Of their funny house and its cozy, narrow,
living room, a room crowded with only four
people in it.
She thought of how the sun would flood in
the southern window and warm the entire room
on a chilly November day.
She thought of the first time she had seen
Terry in his incredibly blue eyes, and how
she'd marveled the first time she saw Chris
suckling at her breast.
What an odd, indescribably joyful sensation
that had been! She thought of her wonderful
vesta, and tried to remember what had finally
happened to it.
Had she toppled it one too many times?
It was a wonder that thing had never killed
her.
Her lips cracked in a faint smile remembering
how many bushes she christened until she finally
figured out the damn brakes and clutch.
And finally she thought of the way the rocks
at world's end felt under her fingers and
how the warmth caressed her skin and allowed
her to feel like she was floating up the wall
-- effortless, tireless, weightless.
It was freedom, and she breathed deep, remembering
the release of her body.
Then she closed her eyes.
[talking] So that's how I dealt with her death.
And the next morning, she was dead, in the
tent.
And they put her in the ruined tent.
And two of those men in the tent with her
also died.
And the man and woman that Kurt was in his
tent with, also died.
1986 has been called the "Black Summer," because
27 people summited, and 13 died in the process
-- most of them trapped at Camp Four in that
storm.
It was also the, you know, three women.
The first three women that made it to the
summit that year, and two of them never made
it home.
Cheerful huh?
We can see where I've been for the past, you
know, yeah. Whoo.
Next time, I'm going to write about, you know,
vacation spots of the rich and famous.
Because this, yeah.
I mean, but it's interesting about passion,
right?
I mean, this chose me.
When Charlotte said, "Oh, look at that.
You know, that means all the women of K2 are
dead."
You think I made the rational like, "Oh, you
know what? That'd be an interesting subject
to research."
Not at all, I -- it just took me and grabbed
me, and here I am.
And it still hasn't let me go.
I still go to K2climb.net, almost every morning
of the climbing season.
Well, every morning of the climbing season,
and almost every morning in non-climbing seasons.
It's just -- it's an odd addiction to a place
that I'll never see.
I'll never get to 8,000 meters, God willing.
And unless it's in a very nice airplane, so.
But it is passion.
Oh, I'm sorry, yes.
Q Would you do it again?
Jennifer Jordan: Do what again?
Q Go through this whole experience?
Knowing what you know now.
Jennifer Jordan: Oh, in retrospect? Yes, absolutely.
Because I think that you don't get to choose.
You're asking me, Would I choose, though.
So, yes, I would, because it's changed my
life in every conceivable way that something
can.
I mean, I started this research, you know,
a single woman living in a third floor walk-up
in Cambridge Massachusetts and loving it.
Believe me, no complaints, working at, you
know, WGBH in Boston and at Harvard.
Had all my little freelance gigs going.
Great life. I biked everywhere.
I never owned a car. It's like "woo hoo"!
My family up the road in Vermont.
My house in the Cape.
Boom! Gave it all up -- rented the condo,
quit all the part-time jobs, gave up the gigs,
got on a plane, went to K2.
And, in that process, I met Jeff, and here
I am in Salt Lake with a house and a car and
a dog and a husband and a book and a film,
and, you know, a new career.
But I don't like the word 'career.' I have
new interests.
Because I think 'career' is too limiting,
especially in these days.
It's too scary to have one job.
The last full-time job I had was in 1990.
And
I said, "Never again."
Just too scary to have somebody else have
that much power.
So now, I just do freelance.
And that's scary too.
But especially when the medical bills -- the
quarterly -- comes, but anyway, I'm rambling
now.
Any more questions? You've been fabulous.
Thank you so much. I'll be -- there are books
here.
If you don't have one. I'll be happy to sign.
Thank you so much. And thank you so much,
Pat, and Google.
>> Thank you.